Thomas Hooker senses it the split-second
the instant that captures the moment and
transforms photography into art that's
based is a moment forget the best you
always need time a lot of time and a lot
of patience and you have to deal with
lots of failed attempts that sometimes
the moment you hope for isn't going to
cut it but sometimes you get lucky give
them to us at this year's Photokina
trade fair in Cologne pictures from his
sixth decade career are on display at
the leica gallery
leading periodicals such as Stan and
Gayo commissioned hooker to take
pictures of people and landscapes all
over the world
the images leave their mark especially
since nothing is manipulated under this
move any desire to Tom Coplin I prefer
to stay undercover so to speak and try
not to be seen just observing standing
somewhere in the corner and thinking
this could become a picture if I'm lucky
these photos were taken while he was
still at school his talent for
composition was already evident
Sooni started working for major
international publications he took these
pictures in 1970s East Germany he was
the first West German photographer to
get permission this is hollow noise Don
the only decoration visible at this not
very attractive housing project was
Erich Honecker and on such a gloomy day
it kind of hits you in the gut what it
does but again I also like this one
because it shows how people found a
niche for themselves it was a big parade
marching in front and these two hid away
and cuddled a bit she put on his hat
that's how people found some space for
themselves simply be human and not to be
completely swallowed up by the state
machine wasn't efficient
the trade fair also presents the latest
advances in photographic equipment
thomas hopko is also interested in new
technologies in 1989 he became the first
german member of the renowned magnum
photo agency and later was made
president one of magnums rules is to
only depict reality that's also his
motto whether working digitally or with
film at the time you'd think twice about
a shot because there were only 36
pictures per roll of film so we worked
more sparingly it was good training
because you knew that the supply of film
was not endless and you'd have to load a
new roll of film Eggman was not loud or
sometimes I'd forget to film at the
hotel and I'd have to go back up coast
photo essays on Muhammad Ali were
unrivaled he went to the u.s. several
times in the 1960s and no one else was
able to get as close to the outspoken
boxer his most famous picture came by
accident during a training session
the pose is that during the break he saw
sitting in the dark and came up to us he
hadn't seen us at first and he said hi
how are you and I had my camera ready
and I shot three pictures our entire
with Conte
indeed the moment that I'm up after his
image of 911 also became famous
Thomas hooker is an old-school
all-rounder revered by young
photographers to
they've been let's and wandering around
the world for the past 40 years always
looking for something going on hope you
get an instinct for it you see that
there might be something there something
might happen it couldn't of us design
the current of us we had
now famous himself popke finds people
taking his picture but he still prefers
to have his own finger on the button